i'm agent mobius by the way  how long have you been here i don't know  it's hard to say you know time passes  differently here in the tva what does  that mean  you'll catch up  this is the first time for me in the  marvel universe they first spoke to me  about iron man and captain america and  even hulk i was like well you know i  don't know  i'm just kidding  i need your unique loki perspective tom  would take us through the world and the  different movies it was amazing because  he just had all this information in his  head we called them the loki lectures  i ended up just sort of writing down  some of the stuff he said and i think  that even worked its way sometimes into  dialogue i was full of enthusiasm and  passion and excitement i really like the  whole look the sets and the costumes you  know let that do the heavy lifting  [Music]